let's start with bitcoin realized market
capitalization the realized cap what the
hell is this and why is it important
yeah so uh this is kind of a mainstay in
a lot of my slides my slide decks with
you guys and this is just kind of a
bigger kind of broad picture of the
bitcoin market so i realized cap is just
a the aggregate basically figure of
every bitcoin that's ever moved and the
price it was last moved so you can
almost think of it as like an organic
price of of bitcoin uh and oftentimes
during both cycles when the bitcoin
price goes parabolic uh realized cap
will will increase um with it but with a
lag um basically because new capital is
flowing in to the asset and old coins
are distributing um and so basically uh
over the last about since summer since
about august
we've seen these capital inflows have
have really started to slow but in
absolute terms they're still pretty big
i mean it's about 90 billion dollars of
capital inflow since august um and to
put that into perspective the next slide
there if you're looking at the the chart
in linear terms that realize cap figure
it's it's basically since since august
we've seen realized cap grow by its
entire figure at the top of the 2017
market that should be labeled uh 2018
january 2018 and it's 90 billion dollars
so in relative terms we haven't seen
really the capital inflows
for bitcoin to be a multi-trillion
dollar asset yet but in in absolute
terms uh the capital inflows are here uh
and they're continuing to come in it's
just uh for the time being uh it's
slowed up a little bit a little
lackluster in relative terms
okay when you think of this realized
market capitalization can you explain uh
is this a uh kind of backwards looking
metric to you in your opinion or is it a
forward-looking metric in terms of do
you use this to understand what's
already happened or do you use this to
try to anticipate something that's going
to happen in the future whether it's
price or other types of metrics
yeah that's a great question i think
with realized cap it's it's more of a
backwards looking metric obviously
because you can see just you know the
price of it at which every coin has ever
moved realize price is just uh realized
cap divided by circulating supply uh
where you can kind of be more
forward-looking with the metric is if
say you take a ratio of and i didn't
include it in the slide deck but that
market value to realize value metric i
present a lot it's just a ratio of price
uh to to this realized price metric and
oftentimes the lower it goes currently
it's about 1.75
really the mdrv ratio below one is like
a generational buying opportunity so um
it's not option that we see it but
that's more of a forward-looking metric
when you take a realized uh a ratio of
these two metrics and so um you know on
a relative base it's a lot more
attractive to buy bitcoin at 40k today
than it was uh at the beginning of last
year um so that's more of a
forward-looking way of looking at this
metric
got it now we've got the realized price
30-day change which is basically just
taking what is it the 30-day kind of
rolling average and looking at how
that's changed over time
yeah so this is just a rate of change uh
almost a derivative not to be confused
with derivative financial markets but uh
for any calculus nerds out there this is
just a derivative
there's a rate of change of this
realized price metric and so you can see
despite since say august we've had 90
billion around there of capital inflows
on a relative basis it hasn't been that
much given just the market size of
bitcoin has obviously grown a lot since
2017. um and so just on a relative basis
just to kind of reiterate uh capital
inflows are here and they're large um
but it's not enough to send bitcoin
parabolic just yet
got it and so then when we go ahead and
we look at the three month futures
annualized rolling basis
when you start thinking about realized
price in relationship to futures or
other types of of more exotic um you
know ways you can get exposure is there
a connection between those two things or
do you look at these as uh kind of
separate and distinct uh types of data
points but it's important to look at
them in totality to actually understand
what's happening with bitcoin
yeah i think um it's you know you kind
of have to look at all of these things
to get a big picture of the market and
the reason i included this chart uh and
obviously
basically this rolling basis the spread
between that futures price uh and the
spot price of bitcoin in this case the
three month futures and then we
annualize that out so say when when
yields are 20 really that's that basis
spread is about five uh five percent uh
but we annualized that that figure out
and so obviously there's a really really
uh strong correlation here and basically
what it's showing is that
while you haven't seen this realized
price or this realized cap metric um
grow a lot expand a lot in relative
terms
this chart is basically telling us that
derivative speculation uh and mostly by
incumbents uh with you know whether you
want to call them whales or uh you know
whether it's crypto hedge funds uh
basically the the speculative bid in
derivative markets has been basically
the largest part of this price action uh
over the last say quarter or two
quarters um
those organic capital flows that we saw
at like late 2020 early 2021 again are
here but it's just not enough to send
bitcoin really parabolic and uh when we
broke that all-time high and went to 69
000 uh it was mostly just derivative
market speculation that's been the
driving force
got it now you've got this uh bitcoin
price
weighted by hourly perps funding rate
which is an absolute mouthful to say uh
explain what this is and then why do you
think this is so important to pay
attention to
yeah so perps is short for perpetual
futures it's another futures market
instrument and basically this is um in
the the purpose of the largest
derivative contracts in crypto and
bitcoin um and so what you can see here
is weighted by the funding rate it
essentially just kind of shows when
bitcoin's a little overheated to the
upside or downside or it's more just
kind of flat uh it's basically a way to
kind of show or to quantify that
speculative bid that speculative premium
um so fun when funding is really high
what that means is that derivatives that
per
uh price that contract price is ahead of
spot market price so that's you know
when that funding rate is very elevated
it's saying that that's the driving
force in the bitcoin market and you know
over the summer we saw the opposite uh
where that funding rate was a lot was
below uh that's the it was a negative
funding rate and so derivatives were
driving the price lower than spot and so
that's why we kind of got a big short
sweeps and so it oscillates uh and
definitely there's kind of a huge
sentiment factor here
but that's kind of a lot of the reason
why bitcoin is is so volatile and we see
these these moves is these derivative
markets and understanding the dynamics
behind them